Disc extre post by
japan airlines
[Music] What
is loved in Japan
is that people can't usually communicate with each other
[Music]
Taihei Machito
to the mountains is the 11th year of the school
uh
ahaan
voodoo
sandast  Po japanese Hocchan
[Music]
noream des Carposic Stars Wizards
I think that costumes for a long time are like cartoons
and become a culture in Japan.
Teyaruna and Pooh Soo A
certain 4th day boots
Tees 4 car owner Shizu House is if this rounded sa Push music
packed with 5x tube anxiety
Bulk os with blue number one Nyan car right Eight character and inside  If the impression of the voice of the person who is doing it
is different, the dream
will be broken again, so I will not make a voice or
love to long.
I won't show it because it will be
EVERYDON p Booby's Bruce er 4 n weezer Masu
car with a doodle
[laughs]
Just because there is a costume like this, it's because
l alone also expresses
latty.
Nao Spain gp 6 s 4 s 3 se
ng Ruwar ec Mylar's example tour
pp Amplant sai zu
[music]